Bridging the mental health Gap when it
comes to people of color Mary Jane
beliesa has more on how medical
providers are working to break cultural
barriers
our resistance is our resilience Dr Mary
Russell is a Navajo psychiatrist
focusing on the health care treatment of
Native Americans she says the economic
impact of covid-19 put a strain on the
indigenous Community it really came to
light all of these issues around the
inequities and poor access to care and
poverty rates you know over two times
higher in indigenous peoples Native
Americans aren't alone mental health
amongst people of color was the main
topic at Wednesday's psychopharmacology
update put on by the Nevada Psychiatric
association Dr Francis G Wu is a
psychiatrist affiliated with UC Davis
Medical he spoke with clinicians on how
they can gather information on what
cultural issues patients of color face
stigma is a major issue especially in
the Asian American Pacific Islander
Community if they even get to a provider
then we do have the potential problem
that the clinicians may not be called
culturally and linguistically competent
to provide the Care Dr Ann Childress a
Las Vegas psychiatrist sees those Trends
hold true right here in the valley I see
fewer Hispanics and fewer
African-American patients they often
don't come in until it's a real crisis
Dr Childress also says some people don't
seek treatment because they can't afford
it we actually pay people to come and
see us we're often looking at
medications that aren't out on the
market yet we're also doing some
non-medication studies and everything I
do is free
and the question begs how do we Bridge
the mental health Gap among people of
color so Dr Lou recommends meaningful
Outreach and also collaboration between
the providers and the communities
involved